المعركه مستمره مع فايروس كورونا هذه
المره ليست مباشره ولكنها مقلقه وكبيره
حيث تختص بالقلوب وازماتها المرتبطه بهذا
الفيروس الكثير من الوفيات بين الشباب
كانت مفاجئه وصادمه لكنها ارتبطت بازمه
القلبيه مع تشخيصها اليوم تثبت دراسات
الجديده ان هذا التشخيص صائم بنسبه كبيره
دراسه جديده نشرت في مجله بحوث الطبيعه
القلبيه الوعائيه تتحدث عن صله بين المرضى
الذين اصيب بكرونا لفتره طويله ومتلازمه
تسرع القلب الانتصاب الوضعي وبحسب مؤلف
الدراسه الرئيسيه الدكتور على الكون
اخصائي امراض القلب في المركز فان متلازمه
تسرع القلب تؤثر على الجهاز العصبي
اللاارادي محدثه خلل كبيره في نظام عمل
القلب
[موسيقى]
وفي تفاصيل دراسه الدكتور قال انكوان حول
ربط كورولا القلب فانها حللت بيانات اكثر
من 300,000 شخص بين 2020 و 2022 من من
اصيب بقبل وجده خطرا الاصابه بمتلازمه
تسرع القلب الوضعي بعد 90 يوما من الحصول
على اللقاح يعتمد على الحمض النووي
الدراسه اشارت الى انها خطر الاصابه
بمتلازمه تسارع القلب الانتصاب الوضعي كان
اكبر بخمس مرات بالنسبه لمن اصيب بكيفنا
[موسيقى]
على ضروره اجراء المزيد من الابحاث مع
التاكيد على ضروره اخذ التطعيمات الخاصه
بفيروس كروم المستجد الذي يذهب وتتفاعلته
في تجارب عديده
المزيد ينتمي الينا من ولايه نور ستارز
دكتور فواز العنزي بروفيسور مساعد امراض
القلب والباطنيه في مستشفى جامعه الجوف
دكتور اهلا بك يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا
صباح العربيه ادراسه تقول لنا خطر الاصابه
متلازمه القلب المتسرع اكبر خمس مرات لدى
الشباب الذين اصيبوا بكوفيت 19
كرونه طويل الامد يحدث هناك في الجهاز
العصبي ترسب الدم في الجزء السفلي خصوصا
الاشخاص اللي يكونوا جالسين يقفون فجاه
يحدث هناك عندهم الدوخه لان يحدث هناك
ترسب للدم في الجزء السفلي من جسم الانسان
لا يعود بالفتره الكافيه او بالسرعه
الكافيه يبدا العمل بسرعه القلب بشكل سريع
بشكل قوي نشعر بالخفقان ثقيل ترويه الدماغ
لذلك ايضا نبدا الشعور في الدوخه والائمه
وحتى ترويه العضلات لذلك نبدا الشعور في
التعب والوهن همم هذه الامراض هي موجوده
ما قبل الكورون حتى لكن كورونا اظهرت كثير
منها على السطح يعني بدات تظهر في اعمار
اقل وبدات تظهر عند ناس اكثر دكتور فواز
انطلاقا لما اشرت اليه هل نفهم من كلامك
هل كل شخص اصيب بفايروس كورونا عليه اجراء
فحص سريري للقلب
طبعا
ولا يوجد فحوصات امانه لهذا المرض بالذات
لا يوجد فحص كلينيكي واضح يقدر يشخص هذا
المرض هو هو فقط اعراض يشتكي منها بعض
الاشخاص لا نستطيع ان نحدد انه والله كل
شخص اصيب فايروس كرونه يعمل فقوصات لهذه
الامراض النسبه قليله تقريبا خمس الاشخاص
يعني نقدر نقول الى تقريبا
بالشكل الاكبر نسبه اقل يعني من المتوقع
كامل طيب دكتور هذه المتلازمه تؤثر على
ضربات القلب تؤدي لتساريحها تؤثر على ضغط
الدم وتؤدي الى الاغماء وكذلك على الجهاز
العصبي ماذا عن ماذا فعاليه من تلقى
اللقاحات مع هذه المتلازمه طبعا لا يوجد
شك ان ايضا الاشخاص اللي اخذوا اللقاحات
فايروس خصوصا اللي معتمده على على الحمض
النووي والمرسال تعرضوا لهذه الامور لكن
اللقاحات الناس اللي اخذوا اللقاحات كانت
كميه هذه الامراض عندهم ظهور هذه الامراض
اقل بكثير من الاشخاص اللي ما اخذوا
اللقاحات اللقاحات كان لها دور بتخفيف وط
على جسم الانسان لان ما يحدث ليحدث ان لما
يجي فارس كورونا ويؤثر على جسم الانسان
جهاز المناعه يبدا يهاجم هذا الفايروس لكن
للاسف يحدث هناك خلل في جهاز المناعه
ويبدا يهاجم حتى بعض الانسجه اللي هي تكون
طبيعيه فتبدا ظهور كثير من الامراض
اللقاحات خففت كثير من وضعت كثير من هذه
الامراض طيب الدكتور فواز يعني هل اليوم
تغير النمط الوبائي للامراض وتم الوصول
والانتقال للامراض جديده لدول العالم
الثالث التوالي الدول المتقدمه ومنها
امراض القلب التي تصيب الشباب هذه المره
بدات تظهر في اعمار اصغر يعني التهابات
عضله القلب التهابات الغشاء الخارجي للقلب
الجلطات القلبيه بدات تظهر حتى في اعمار
العشرينات والثلاثينات وللامانه ليس فقط
فايروس كورونا طبيعه الحياه طبيعه الغذاء
اللي تناوله قله الحركه قله الرياضه
التدخين عدم الاهتمام في ارتفاع سكر الدم
وضغط الدم هذه العوامل كلها ادت الى ظهور
هذه الامراض في اعمار اصغر لكن بالنسبه
الفيروسات من من يعني من البشريه
الفيروسات تعمل طفرات معينه وتظهر باشكال
معينه فهذا الامر بالنسبه لنا مو جديد
للامانه لكن للاسف فايروس كانت وضعتها جدا
كبيره على البشريه
واحنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر من ولايه نور
ولينا دكتور فواز العنزي بروفيسير ومساعد
امراض القلب والباطنيه في مستشفى جامعه
ديوك